BOBBY FLAY: What's up everybody?
Thanks for being here.
I'm very excited to be here.
I've wanted to come
here for a long time.
A lot of my friends who
are chefs have cooked here,
and I always kind
of felt left out.
So I'm glad that I got an
invitation to come here.
So today I'm going to make
a version of carnitas.
This is from my new
book, "Bobby Flay FIT."
I have a new book coming out
in just a handful of days.
And it is about eating
in a healthful way
and just living a
healthier lifestyle.
You know, as a chef, I
get asked all the time
how I stay in shape.
And so I figured it was time
to write a cookbook about that.
And so today's dish is actually
a play on a classic Mexican
or southwestern dish called
carnitas, which you've all
seen carnitas tacos everywhere.
And most of the time its--
carnitas are cooked
with a pork shoulder,
which has tons of fat in it.
And then they fry it at the
end and make it really crispy,
which is always a
good thing, of course.
But I'm going to actually make
a much simpler version of it,
a healthier version, and one
that, actually, you can cook
in a very quick amount of time.
So here's the deal.
So we're going to make
the pork carnitas.
It's going to have a pomegranate
and chipotle glaze on it.
And we're going to make
some guacamole, which
is, I think, the recipe that
you guys are all actually
going to take away and then
use more than anything else.
But that's OK.
I mean, that's how
I cook my food.
I make things with--
I make one component at a time,
and then you can sort of mix
and match them.
They don't necessarily
have to all go together.
But in this case, they will.
We're going to make
some pickled red onions.
I'll show you how I
make those as well.
Now usually when I make
pickled red onions,
like if you watch
"Beat Bobby Flay,"
I make a lot of pickled
red onions for garnish.
Because they're crispy,
they're tart, they're sweet.
They can be really pretty.
And a lot of times I'll just
use, like, some grenadine
and some vinegar.
So you want something
acidic, and then you
want something sweet.
In this case, we're going
to use some lime juice,
and some water, and
then some cane sugar.
They tell me that cane sugar
is better than processed sugar,
so we're going to use that.
And you just put
this on the stove,
and then you bring it to a boil.
And once you get it to a
boil, once you get to a boil,
it's ready to go.
You don't need to
reduce it down.
You don't need to cook it
for a long period of time.
You just want to
have that solution
to pour over the onions.
And the way I cut
my onions for this
is, I cut them very thinly
in sort of half moons.
So we're going to just
take the peel off.
And then, very
carefully, you just
want to slice half moons of
the onion, just like this.
[KNIFE HITTING WOODEN CUTTING
BOARD]
And the great thing
about this is,
like, when you
pickle jalapenos, you
can use the same recipe, the
pickling recipe, for anything
that you want to pickle.
You can pickle jalapenos.
You can pickle some cauliflower
if you want, some carrots.
It's really up to you.
Pickled vegetables have
become, obviously, really,
really important.
I'm finding that
in my restaurant.
Like, at Gato,
people are basically
eating fish and
vegetables these days.
I mean, it's amazing how
many vegetables we have.
In fact, the number one dish
is a kale and wild mushroom
paella.
And it's a vegetarian paella.
And we've been open for
about four years in March,
and every single night since
the day the restaurant's opened
it's been the number one dish.
I would have never predicted
that four years ago--
that a vegetarian dish
would be the number one
dish on my restaurant menu--
ever.
I mean, in fact, I almost
didn't put it on the menu.
I'm, like, this is
never going to sell.
[LAUGHTER]
That tells you how
much we know-- nothing.
OK.
So very thinly sliced onions--
and do we have a
mixing bowl for this?
This one?
OK.
[BOWL CLINKS AGAINST COUNTER]
Found it!
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So we put some onions in here.
And then you just
bring this to a boil,
and then you just basically
just pour this over.
And as the pickling
liquid sits on the onions,
it will just pickle the
onions more and more.
And you don't have to remove
the pickling liquid at all.
In fact, actually, I
like to just put it
in a Mason jar, put
in my refrigerator.
When I need some,
I just take them.
And it just preserves
them, and you just
have it for a long time.
And you can really go for,
you know, months and months,
really, when you pickle
a vegetable like that.
So it's really cool to have.
And usually, like
in the beginning
of the summer in my
house out East, I usually
pickle a bunch of
red onions, and I
jalapenos, basically,
for the whole summer.
So when I'm making, like,
fish tacos with my friends,
or even a dish like this, I
know that those two components
are already done.
And I mean, that's
key to cooking.
At some point, you as the cook
want to get out of the kitchen
and to the table.
So that's one of
the ways I do it.
OK, so those are
the pickled onions,
and we'll bring those
back later to garnish.
And now we're going to
make a glaze for the pork.
So as I said before, we're
going to use pork tenderloin.
And we have two components
for the pork tenderloin.
A spice rub-- we want to create
some flavor and some texture
on the outside of
the pork tenderloin--
and then also a glaze.
So for the glaze, it's going
to be some pomegranate molasses
and some pomegranate juice.
So basically, if you reduce
the pomegranate juice,
you get pomegranate molasses.
It's a much thicker, syrupy,
like, pomegranate juice,
and it's very thick.
So you can find this in--
basically, you can find
this everywhere now.
I mean, this has become a very
sort of fashionable product
in American cooking.
So some pomegranate juice--
you can use cranberry
juice if you
can't find pomegranate juice.
But again, obviously, you
can find it everywhere now.
Some pomegranate molasses
for some thickness, and then
some chipotle puree--
anybody here know
what a chipotle is?
A what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BOBBY FLAY: Mayo?
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: You got
to Google that, man.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BOBBY FLAY: Smoked jal-- yes.
And you're speaking
with an accent.
Do you come from the
land of chipotle?
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: You're Mexican?
There you go.
So really, we
shouldn't have actually
let you raise your hand.
But thank you for importing
the knowledge here.
That's great.
So yes, smoked jalapenos--
and they're great.
I mean, it's smoky.
It's fiery.
And I add this ingredient
to so many of my dishes
when I just kind of need
something to wake it up.
Chipotles are magic.
They're really magic.
Do you use them a lot?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BOBBY FLAY: Yeah,
they're fantastic.
You know, in some ways,
they've almost become a cliche.
I mean, there's obviously a
restaurant chain all over,
on every street
corner, named Chipotle.
But that doesn't mean that
I don't want to use this,
because this thing is so good.
OK.
It's smoky.
It's fiery.
And that's the thing
that I like to do.
I like to sort of
counterbalance.
If I have something
sweet or tart,
I want to add something
that's a little sour or spicy.
And that's the key
to my food-- where
there's lots of flavor
going on, but the balance
is really the key.
So in this case, you have
the tart and the sweetness
of the pomegranate,
and then you have
the smoky and the
fieriness of the chipotles,
and then, when this cooks
together and becomes
like a nice glaze on the
outside of the pork--
so you think about it.
You have the pork.
The pork doesn't
have a ton of flavor,
because there's not
a lot of fat in it.
But it's going to have the
spice rub on the outside of it,
and you're going to have the
pomegranate and the chipotle
flavoring it--
good contrast of texture,
good contrast of flavors.
[CLEARS THROAT]
[GAS RANGE CLICKING ON]
All right.
So we're going to let this cook.
All right, now let's
get to the pork.
So three ingredients
for the spice rub--
some chili powder, some
coriander seed, and then
some cumin.
Cumin is very, very powerful.
So you just need a little bit.
And then some salt and pepper.
Actually, I need
a little bit more
because I've got pork there.
[UTENSIL CLINKING AGAINST GLASS
BOWL]
Again, this is something that
you could do way ahead of time.
You know, I have tons
of different spice
blends in my cupboard at home.
I have the Spanish spices
and the Moroccan spices.
At this point, I
forget what's in them.
[LAUGHTER]
It doesn't even matter anymore.
So I just pick one and just
take one and just season it,
season whatever meat
or fish I'm using.
[PAN CLANGING]
[GAS RANGE CLICKING ON]
OK, good, all right.
A little bit of canola oil--
now a lot of people ask me why
I don't cook with olive oil.
I use extra virgin
olive oil all the time,
but I never really cook with it.
I have two kinds of
oil in my cupboard--
I have canola oil, and I
have extra virgin olive oil.
I use canola oil to cook with.
And I use extra virgin
olive oil not to cook with.
So I finish things with
extra virgin olive oil,
like a piece of
grilled fish that
has a nice spice rub on it.
It just needs a little
bit of moisture,
a little splatter of
extra virgin olive oil,
it becomes a sauce for you.
Extra virgin olive
oil is very thick.
It's very viscous.
And if you cook it, I
find it becomes bitter.
Not every cook and
chef agrees with me,
but that's how I feel about it.
When I'm cooking something,
I want something very light
in flavor and in
texture, and that's
why canola oil really works.
I don't want this pork
to taste like the oil.
I want it to taste like pork.
That's just my philosophy--
not everybody agrees.
Giada De Laurentiis and I
fight about this all the time.
I mean, seriously-- because
she thinks extra virgin olive
oil from Italy should be
used on everything, no matter
what, whether you're
cooking it in a pan
or using it for
dressing, whatever.
And so she's, like, I would
never cook with canola oil.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
True story, that's
what we debate about.
OK, so some spices on the pork,
just going to mix this up,
because you want to make sure
it gets distributed evenly.
[METAL CLINKING]
Little more spice-- now you can
just really smell the cumin.
So cumin-- if you're
not familiar with cumin,
it's a spice that you'll find
in lots of Latin cooking,
lots of Cuban cooking,
Mexican cooking,
South American cooking.
And it's very earthy.
It almost has a musty flavor,
but a little bit really
goes a long ways.
When I cook beans, I put
a little cumin in it.
It really kind of wakes it up.
But sometimes, if you put too
much, then you can overpower.
So just be careful with it.
Same thing with the chipotles--
they can hurt you, for sure.
All right.
Now you see my pan is starting
to smoke a little bit?
That's exactly what
you want to see.
Let me move this out of the way.
[PAN CLINKS]
And we're going to put
one layer of the pork--
now this is a very common
mistake for a home cook.
They have a lot of pork.
They pour it all into the pan.
And what happens is
it starts to steam
it as opposed to saute it.
So what I want to do
is I want to make sure
that every piece of pork is
touching the bottom of the pan.
We want direct heat.
If I have pork on the
bottom of the pan,
and then pork on top of the
pork, what's going to happen?
It's going to create steam.
And then the pork is
just going to steam.
We're not going to get that
nice crust on the outside.
So basically, the way to do
it is you have to be patient
and do it in batches.
And you don't want to
crowd the pan too much.
You want to give it some room.
Because otherwise, the
same thing will happen.
And I always get a little
extra salt and pepper.
That's the other thing.
I mean, the difference between
a professional cook and a home
cook with seasoning is that--
for the most part, not
100% across the board--
but for the most part, the
thing that I see the most
is that a home cook is a little
more timid with seasoning.
And in my kitchen, I'm
constantly saying to my cooks,
did you season it on both
sides with salt and pepper?
Did you put enough?
Because that's the
basics of cooking
is seasoning the food first.
It's amazing when I
go to restaurants--
I'll go to a good
restaurant, and I'll
notice that they're not
even seasoning the food.
Like, the food looks beautiful.
It's fancy.
But there's something
just missing.
And a lot of times, it's
just simple salt and pepper.
That's where you need to start.
All right.
So we're going to let this cook.
You guys have any questions?
We going to do the
questions now, or--
yeah?
All right.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
[INAUDIBLE]
BOBBY FLAY: Yeah, you
have to use the mic.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
BOBBY FLAY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: When you
say a pinch of salt,
how do you know what a
pinch of salt actually is?
BOBBY FLAY: That's
a great question.
And I'm really the
wrong person to ask,
because I just go like this.
I mean, a pinch is this.
So you take three of your
fingers and your thumb--
[LAUGHTER]
And I use kosher
salt. And kosher salt
is-- it's large
granules of salt, right?
So the right way to season--
I won't put more in here,
I'll just do it over here--
is you take it in your hands.
So this is a pinch, all right?
There's your answer.
I don't know how much that is.
And you crush it
in your fingers.
So as you're crushing
it, you season the food.
And then you season
from up here, not here.
Because if you season
close to the food,
you're going to just get pieces
of salt in particular places.
If you're seasoning
from up here,
you'll distribute
it much better.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BOBBY FLAY: Sure!
Good question.
I wasn't ready for that.
So now you can see
the pork is getting
nice and crispy and
crusty on the outside.
I don't know if
you can see that.
But you want that.
You want that nice
crustiness on the outside.
And pork tenderloin-- it
cooks very, very fast.
So the one thing I don't
want to do is overcook it.
And you know, the
days of cooking pork
until it's completely
destroyed is really over.
You want to cook
it around medium.
A tiny bit of pink
inside is fully fine.
You want to keep some
of the juiciness.
And then we're going to
take some of our glaze--
that's all right.
We're going to take
some of the glaze--
so that we remember, the
pomegranate, the chipotles,
and the pomegranate juice.
Take some of this, and just
pour this over the pork.
Mm, this looks good.
[LAUGHTER]
Just give it a quick turn.
And that's basically
just about done.
I'm going to take a
little bit of cilantro--
[CHOPPING KNIFE ON BOARD]
--coarsely chopped.
And you always finish at the
very end with the fresh herbs.
Put the fresh herbs at the very,
very end, almost like right
before you serve it.
So I'm not even going
to actually mix this in.
I'm going to leave
it site there.
And then I'm going to start
working on the guacamole.
Any questions before
we go forward?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BOBBY FLAY: Um--
AUDIENCE: How do you
know that the meat--
BOBBY FLAY: Well,
in this case, it's
going to cook really quickly.
So I mean, if you were
cooking a pork tenderloin,
you'd want to make sure
it was, like, one--
what's the safe?
155 for a pork tenderloin.
So a meat thermometer,
which I barely ever
use because I use this
touch, this method,
which is just experience.
But really, you should test it.
So at 150, 155, you should
take it out and let it rest.
Because it's going to
continue to cook it till it's
stone cold.
So that would be--
AUDIENCE: I usually cut meat
open when it's on the stove.
And I feel like I'm letting
out the flavor in it.
BOBBY FLAY: Yes, you're
not doing that right.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: Yeah, I mean, if
any of my cooks take a knife
and put it in the steak
to see if it's done--
AUDIENCE: My husband
doesn't know any better.
So we're good.
BOBBY FLAY: You just
cover it with some sauce?
Listen, that works, too.
Don't worry about it.
I mean, all of a sudden,
it's sliced steak, right?
Anyway, so yeah, I mean a
meat thermometer is really
the way to go.
OK, so we're going to let the
pork rest there for a second.
Now we're going to
make some guacamole.
So you want your avocados--
obviously, when you
go to the store,
the avocados are never ripe.
I mean, it's crazy.
You have to dig.
I mean, I've had like--
it's almost like silent
wars at the avocado stand.
Because you know, the
person is up there,
and there's, like, two
ripe avocados out of 400.
And you get it, and they look
at you with a dirty look.
Here's the thing.
You have to dig
underneath the avocados.
Because a lot of
times, what happens
is the avocados on
the top aren't ripe,
and the ones that are
being covered by the light
are actually ripening quicker.
So when you're in Whole Foods
or wherever you're shopping,
just make sure that you
go through the bottom,
and look under the bottom,
because you'll definitely
find some ripe avocados.
You cannot make guacamole with
avocados that are not ripe.
It's just not good.
I mean, it doesn't
have the right texture.
It doesn't have
the right flavor.
Guacamole is one of those
really sensual things, I think.
And the avocado is the most
important thing in guacamole.
OK, so we have ripe
avocados, which is nice.
I didn't have to go
digging for them.
And so what I do
is I slice around
the big, sort of
pit in the middle.
[KNIFE CLANGING]
And then I take the bottom
of my knife, and I just--
very carefully put the bottom
of the knife in the pit,
and I turn it.
OK?
And this way, the pit's out.
Now don't do this.
[LAUGHTER]
You have a thumb right here.
Just go like that.
I've seen some bad
accidents that way.
[PIT RATTLES IN BOWL]
All right.
So then, with the avocado
on the cutting board,
you just make diamonds in
the avocado, in the shell.
How many people here put
garlic in their guacamole?
We're going to have a fight.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm really a guacamole purist.
And I'll show you how
I make the guacamole.
I mean, this is the recipe
I've been using, basically,
for my whole life.
I don't like garlic
in my guacamole,
but obviously a
lot of people do.
And that's totally fine.
It's just one of those things
you either do put it in,
or you don't put in.
I don't, and I just like
a really clean flavor.
Do you have a spoon?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
[UTENSILS CLINKING]
BOBBY FLAY: Oh, here's
all my ingredients.
Can you hold that?
OK.
Oh, I'll take this.
Thanks.
OK.
All right.
So we take the sort
of pre-diced avocado,
and just drop it right in.
Does anybody here make their
guacamole in a food processor?
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, there's somebody in
there, like, oh, not really.
That's avocado puree.
We don't want that.
Texture is so important
when it comes to food.
I mean, I always say,
it's really simple.
Good food is about great
flavor and contrasted texture.
And in this case, I'm going to
show you how to continue that.
All right, so we
have some cilantro
We have some red onions.
We have some serrano chilies.
Serranos looks like a jalapeno.
They're a little
bit more tapered.
They're a little bit spicier.
But they have a good
pepper background flavor.
That's why I like using them.
You can easily use
jalapenos, no problem.
Sometimes, when I'm lazy,
I take the jalapenos
in my refrigerator,
the pickled ones,
and I put those in as well.
They have a lot of flavor.
But this is a really kind
of fresher way to do it.
So some serrano chilies--
and I don't take the seeds out.
I leave the seeds in.
That's up to you.
I mean, it will be a little
bit spicier with the seeds in.
That's OK.
And then, some lime juice--
and you guys know
this trick, right?
You roll the lime to get the
most amount of juice out of it?
OK, coarsely chop some cilantro.
And then I throw everything
in at the same time.
I don't mix after each one.
That's a mistake that I
see a lot of people doing,
and then you're going to ruin
the texture of the guacamole.
So some chilies, some
cilantro, some fresh lime,
some red onion, and then
some salt and pepper--
a pinch of salt or two--
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: --and then
I just take a fork--
SPEAKER 1: Here you go
BOBBY FLAY: --I got it.
And I just kind of mash
it down a little bit
and fold it together, just
until all the ingredients
are incorporated.
[FORK SCRAPING SIDES OF BOWL]
You've got to taste
everything you eat--
make.
You're not tasting this?
I want to know, because
if they're not tasting it,
it's perfect.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a little spicy.
It's got a right
amount of salt. I mean,
you're looking for
all those things.
Does it have enough
acidity-- if not, a little
squeeze more of lime.
It's definitely got
some heat to it.
I can taste the serranos.
I can taste the red onion.
And most importantly,
I taste the avocados.
And you can see
the texture of it--
that's it.
And that's because I
only mixed it one time.
So you put the
avocados in the bottom.
You put all the ingredients,
ready to go, on top.
And then you just
kind of fold it in.
And then it's done.
OK, so we have the pork.
We have the red onions.
And we have our guacamole.
We can plate, right?
Any questions so far?
Any other questions?
Wow.
[CLINKING]
OK.
All right.
[PLATTER BANGING]
Get this nice, beautiful
Google platter.
[LAUGHTER]
Man, that is heavy.
Now classically, corn
tortillas-- not flour,
corn tortillas.
Or you could use
flour, but again,
if you want it to be a little
bit more sort of fit-like,
lettuce leaves.
And I find the best ones
are butter lettuce or Boston
lettuce.
Just because of their
shape, they hold together.
But they're soft
at the same time.
And then, we just take
some of our pork carnitas--
and don't fill it up too
much, just a little bit.
OK.
And then a little bit
of the guacamole--
so you know, you're getting
the tenderness from the pork.
You're getting that sort
of smooth, cooling effect
from the avocado
and the guacamole.
And the the pickled
red onions is
going to add that crunch to it.
Here we are.
And then, for garnish,
some pomegranate
seeds to bring-- to reinforce
the flavor of the pomegranate
glaze and a squeeze of lime.
There we go, pork carnitas.
[APPLAUSE]
Can we hand these out or not?
I promise you won't die.
[LAUGHTER]
There's only four of them.
This is like being
at the avocado stand.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll just-- I'll let
you guys fight it out.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
To go back to the
avocados, if you
are unable to actually
find a ripe avocado,
how do you ripen it?
BOBBY FLAY: To ripen
an avocado, you
put it in a brown
paper bag or something,
get it away from the light.
And it will ripen.
It doesn't take that long.
A couple of days, and you
will have ripe avocados.
It goes really fast.
You guys didn't really
share with your friends.
That was it.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: Anybody else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: My eight-year-old
is, like, super obsessed
with "Beat Bobby Flay."
BOBBY FLAY: Oh, is that right?
AUDIENCE: She's always
wondering, like,
why do they all want
to beat Bobby Flay?
So she sent me a
bunch of questions.
BOBBY FLAY: OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm only
going to ask--
BOBBY FLAY: How many are there?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'll only ask one.
BOBBY FLAY: Good.
AUDIENCE: So what made
you start cooking?
BOBBY FLAY: What made
me start cooking?
I dropped out of high school.
So tell her not to do that.
I dropped out of high school in
10th grade, and I needed a job.
And so I went to
work in a restaurant.
I started out as a
busboy, actually,
for the first two weeks.
And then I was offered
a job in the kitchen.
And I was, like, OK.
I mean, you know,
I was 17-years-old.
I had no idea what I was doing.
But I fell in love with it.
And then I went
to culinary school
after that, about a
year and a half later.
And I've basically been doing
the same thing for 35 years.
AUDIENCE: Where did you
go to culinary school?
BOBBY FLAY: Well, it used to
be called The French Culinary
Institute on Grand
Street and Broadway.
And now it's called the
International Culinary Center,
yes.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BOBBY FLAY: Yes.
I'm really upset
that they changed
the name of my only alma mater.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Other than your
own restaurants, what's
your favorite in New York City?
BOBBY FLAY: I like Via Carota,
which is an Italian trattoria
right over on Grove Street.
It reminds me of walking
down the street in Rome,
and you getting lucky
that you found this place.
The food is very simple,
but executed perfectly.
And it's a place that
I feel like I can go
all the time, Via Carota, yeah.
I shouldn't have told you
that, because now it's
going to be hard to get in.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
It was super good.
BOBBY FLAY: Good.
AUDIENCE: How long do you pickle
onions for, any pickling--
jalapenos, et cetera?
BOBBY FLAY: I mean, you
should probably pickle them
for at least a couple hours.
But then you just have them--
you just put the whole
thing in a Mason jar
and keep them in
your refrigerator.
AUDIENCE: You don't want
to use those, though?
Because you just made them?
BOBBY FLAY: No, exactly--
I used these.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
BOBBY FLAY: These
were made when?
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
BOBBY FLAY: All right, yeah.
But they're still crunchy.
They're sweet and tart.
They're good.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
BOBBY FLAY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
in terms of the oil you used.
What about coconut oil?
Because in high temperature,
at least my whatever,
Google searches have said
that coconut oil least
is a little better than--
because the way it breaks down.
BOBBY FLAY: I mean, honestly,
I'm not an oil expert.
But the thing about
coconut oil, is
it really tastes like coconut.
It has flavor.
I like canola because
it's a lot cleaner flavor.
A lot of people I know use
coconut oil, and they like it.
So that's actually
a good oil to use.
Grapeseed oil is another
one that people use.
Peanut oil, also, is
one that can actually
take very high heat.
See, that's what
happens is-- if you
want to get your saute pan
smoking to sear something,
and you have extra
virgin olive oil in it,
it's going to make it bitter.
And these lighter oils,
coconut oil included,
can withstand the higher heat
without loosing its integrity.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So besides
going to culinary school,
if you're someone who's
interested in home
cooking, what are your tips
to improve your skills?
Like, what's a good way
to continue to get better?
BOBBY FLAY: Buy all my books.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: Um, look, you
know, as you guys know better
than anybody, you have access
to so many things online.
And in fact, like, you
know, on "Beat Bobby Flay,"
I get challenged to things
that I've never done before.
And I spend-- like,
when I can't sleep at 3
o'clock in the morning--
I'm watching YouTube videos
of dishes from Ethiopia.
I mean, I'm serious--
like, to see what they are like.
And it really gives me--
it's actually way better
than just reading a recipe.
Because you get to see
how the dish continues
to evolve as they cook it
when they add the ingredients.
And that's a big difference.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thanks.
BOBBY FLAY: I mean, there's
so much how-to online now.
And there's no substitute
for experience.
Do it.
And I always say to people,
like, a lot of times people
will say to me, I'm a
disaster in the kitchen.
I don't know how to cook
anything, but I need to learn.
For whatever reason, they've
decided this is the time.
And I always say to them,
you need five dishes.
Figure out how to make a
fish dish, a pasta dish,
you know, a steak, a
salad, something else.
And then, once you
have those five dishes,
and you continue to
make them over and over,
you're going to get tired
of making them the same way.
And it's going to
force you to sort
of start to add
things to the dishes
and move onto the next thing.
But think about
all the experience
that you're getting
making those dishes.
That's the key.
It's like when you ask me-- how
do you know when it's cooked?
I know when it's cooked because
I can look at it and tell you.
But that's because I've
had a lot of experience.
The more you do something, the
more comfortable you'll be.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
That was a nice YouTube plug.
I like that.
But I was just
wondering if there's
any, like, city or
small town that you've
been to that kind
of surprised you
with how good the restaurants
were or the food was there
that's not like New York City
where you have everything.
BOBBY FLAY: Cities?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like, a
smaller city or something.
BOBBY FLAY: I mean, honestly,
the food in this country
is getting to be amazing
everywhere in this country.
I mean, it never
used to be that way.
You know, I was
just in Albuquerque,
and what's going on
there is amazing.
Obviously, a place
like Charleston
has blown up already.
Seattle, Minneapolis--
amazing food there--
actually, one of
the chefs-- this
is what's happening
a lot, because
of the economies
of scale of opening
a restaurant in New York, which
frankly, have become close
to impossible.
I mean, it's really hard.
And a really great chef, who is
the chef de cuisine of Danielle
for many years, his
name is Gavin Kaysen--
he did his time with Danielle.
He got great reviews
under Danielle,
and it was, like, OK,
it's time for me to go.
Now most people
would, at that point,
find a restaurant in New
York, a space in New York,
get a partner, and
they'd open a restaurant.
He decided to go back to
his roots in Minneapolis.
That's why I thought about it.
And he's killing it.
You know, the economies of scale
in a city like that work way
better.
And now there's an
appreciation for good food,
and people are willing to pay
for it basically everywhere
in this country.
That never used
to be the truth--
the case.
But it took us a long time
for us, in this country,
to catch up to the rest of
the world in terms of food's
important to us.
And I think, in
most cases, we've
surpassed the rest of the world.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BOBBY FLAY: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So I was just
wondering what you'd--
BOBBY FLAY: I feel like
you're going to challenge me.
AUDIENCE: No.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: You just came at me.
Like, you kind of like squared
off with me right there.
[LAUGHTER]
What's your-- come
on, what's the dish?
All right, let's go.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering, like,
when you cook at home, just
for yourself, how
do you approach it.
Do you try to make crazy things?
Or do you just
have a go to dish?
BOBBY FLAY: Like, bacon,
egg, and cheese sandwich?
I mean, chefs cook for
themselves really simply
at home.
You know, I'm trying
to think about--
like, only for myself, or
for having a dinner party?
Just for myself, I mean,
it's really not much.
It's really like an egg
sandwich or something.
I'm never home for
dinner, because I'm always
in the restaurants
or somewhere else.
And I'm never really
home for lunch.
So it's usually breakfast.
Or, like, if I've been
out late, and I've
had a couple of cocktails,
and I want something
to sort of quench my
hunger, it literally
is, like, a bacon, egg,
and cheese sandwich.
And it's nothing
that's better ever--
hot sauce, boom.
That's the truth.
I could have said,
yeah, you know,
I take a little foie
gras and some caviar.
That doesn't happen.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
saying that--
did you get that?
Or do you want me
to say it again?
I remember that was one of
the more difficult ones.
What's the most difficult
"Beat Bobby Flay" or anything
that you've been
challenged to make?
BOBBY FLAY: It's too--
that was a tough one.
Listen, when I get taken
out of my wheelhouse,
those are the best shows.
Because I'm like-- I'm
stumped, for the most part.
But no matter what, I'm
going to cook something.
And a lot of times it's never
an authentic version of it,
because I don't know
the authentic version.
I'm making sort of what I
think the dish might be,
or sort of a play on it.
So I think it was-- you
know, I brought up Ethiopia,
because Marcus
Samuelson challenged me
to the national
dish of Ethiopia.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know-- I don't even
remember the name of it.
And so basically-- and
then somebody else--
it was an Iranian dish?
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
BOBBY FLAY: Yeah.
It was-- yeah.
You know, so those--
and a dish like bibimbap--
at least bibimbap
is a dish that I
like to eat, right?
So when I go to a
Korean restaurant,
I'm always ordering bibimbap.
So I mean, I get it.
You know, it's vegetables.
It's meats, whatever.
It's rice.
It's not going to be authentic.
So if somebody from South Korea
landed at the table, they'd be,
like, what is this?
But that said, it's
my version of it.
And actually, I
thought the bibimbap--
I lost the bibimbap one.
But I was, like, I
think I have a chance.
[LAUGHTER]
The other two dishes, I
literally had no chance.
I mean, I was just kind of
watching what they were doing.
And I'm like, all
right, chili powder.
You know?
OK, rice, saffron, great.
And kind of, like, I just
tried to make it taste good.
That's ultimately
what I try to do.
And the culinary team
behind the scenes,
who procure all the
ingredients and everything,
there's a guy there
who says to me--
he's, like, the reason
why you win sometimes
is because you understand
the yummy factor.
So when the judges
taste it, they're,
like, oh, this tastes good.
And that's the key.
It's that the judges
don't see who made what.
It's blind.
They're only tasting the
dish after it's been plated,
and we're just standing there.
So they don't know
who made which dish.
So I always know that there
are certain things-- like I
was talking to you guys about
before, where you combine sour
and tart and sweet and spicy,
and all those things that make
you go, oh, this tastes good.
So even if it's not authentic,
if I can make it taste good
and I don't know what
I'm doing, I have a shot.
It doesn't work out
most of the time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BOBBY FLAY: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
BOBBY FLAY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Can you recommend
where to get good fresh fruits
and vegetables in Manhattan
and maybe the Upper West Side?
BOBBY FLAY: What are you saying?
You don't like
where you shop now?
AUDIENCE: I think it's hard
to find good, fresh fruits
and vegetables in the city.
BOBBY FLAY: I will say that
when you go to the West Coast,
it's a lot easier.
And you know, I guess that's
just because of the place
that we live in.
You know, I find it,
especially in the winter,
it's really hard to find
fabulous vegetables here,
because it is what it is.
In the summertime, I
find it a lot easier.
I mean, I probably
shop where you shop.
Where do you shop?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BOBBY FLAY: How
about Whole Foods?
AUDIENCE: Whole
Foods [INAUDIBLE]..
BOBBY FLAY: OK.
Then go to Whole Foods.
[LAUGHTER]
That's where I shop.
AUDIENCE: There's a farmers'
market on 97th Street.
[INAUDIBLE]
BOBBY FLAY: The
farmers' markets--
the farmers' markets in
the city are wonderful.
Again, in the summer,
they're amazing.
In the winter, it
gets a little--
there's lots of potatoes.
You know?
So I mean-- but I think that
Whole Foods does a good job.
I really do.
AUDIENCE: What are
you going to do
with the rest of that guacamole?
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: Good question.
Well, you need
chips or something.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'll figure it out.
BOBBY FLAY: Do we have
chips in this place?
OK.
Anybody else?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: What's
next food trend?
There was kind of Greek yogurt.
What's the next thing that's
going to hit the market that
will change a food category?
BOBBY FLAY: Oh, god.
Any guesses?
I don't know.
I'm the worst at this.
If I tell you what the
next food trend is,
you know it's not
going to be that.
What do you think?
What's happening?
I mean--
JENNIFER: I think [INAUDIBLE]
ancient grain [INAUDIBLE]..
BOBBY FLAY: Yeah.
Beans are going to
take over grains?
JENNIFER: Beans [INAUDIBLE].
BOBBY FLAY: Jennifer is my
public relations person.
So she knows more than
I do about trends.
But I think that
we're going to go--
I think, in the
big picture, there
we're going to continue to eat
more and more vegetables, more
fish.
And meat is going to take a
side dish position in the world.
That's just what
seems to be happening.
And I think this is just
going to continue to be
more of a trend in that way.
I mean, I feel like
we've exhausted
every food trend in every
country in the world so far.
It's amazing.
I love Middle Eastern
food, because it's
so beautiful and so
healthful and so flavorful.
I mean, I think those
are the key things now.
You want things that
are good for you,
that have a lot of flavor,
and that are really
pretty to look at.
And I think that a
cuisine like that--
Israeli cuisine is amazing.
It's like that as well.
I mean, when I order at home,
I order from Taim a lot.
You know that place?
Oh, it's the best
falafel in New York.
But it goes beyond that.
I mean, it's, like,
Israeli cuisine,
and it's so good, so healthful.
Pomegranates are everywhere.
Anybody else?
I know that wasn't helpful.
But I don't know.
AUDIENCE: On the
food trend topic,
is there a current food trend
that you're just so sick of?
Maybe it's, like,
a certain dish--
BOBBY FLAY: Poke bowls--
I feel like Poke bowls--
here's the thing
about a Poke bowl.
What has to be great
about a Poke bowl--
the fish.
So I know that there's all these
fast, casual environments doing
it.
I get a little
concerned about that.
I don't want
inexpensive Poke bowl.
You know what I'm saying?
That's just my thing.
And they just came on so
strong, out of nowhere.
It's crazy.
I mean, I know you
know that, obviously,
in Hawaii, that's where
the trend sends from.
That was my answer.
I don't know.
I'm not going to say kale.
I want kale to
stay here forever.
It's so good.
I mean, when I want
to go to a restaurant
and order a kale salad,
I feel like I should not
be ordering a kale salad, but
I really want it, you know?
It's so good.
I love that black kale.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: What is the
last thing you googled?
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: What was the
last thing I googled?
[LAUGHTER]
I have to think.
I can't remember the last
time I googled something.
JENNIFER: [INAUDIBLE]
BOBBY FLAY: No, I know.
I use it all the time,
as everybody else does.
You just put me on the spot.
I can't remember.
I'll think about.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I'll follow up with it.
BOBBY FLAY: Oh.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
JENNIFER: [INAUDIBLE]
BOBBY FLAY: No, I--
Elise sent me the address.
AUDIENCE: You were just
speaking about pomegranates.
Do you have a trick or a really
great way of cutting one open?
BOBBY FLAY: Yes.
Did I forget to do that?
Is that what you're telling me?
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So I cut it open like that.
But the way you
get the seeds out--
I think that's what
you're asking, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BOBBY FLAY: OK.
An easier way to get the seeds
out is you take a wooden spoon,
and you put a little bit of
pressure on the pomegranate,
and you just whack them out.
[BANGING NOISES]
This way, you don't have
to pick through them.
When we were kids, we used to
eat these in grammar school.
I don't know why.
But we called them
Chinese apples.
That's what we knew them as.
There you go.
And some of them go in the bowl.
Some of them don't.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BOBBY FLAY: Oh,
you're very welcome.
I'm sure you didn't
know how to do that.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I have a
question for you.
So growing up, I've watched
a lot of your shows,
a lot of your different shows.
And even getting older, like,
continue watching your shows.
And being in this
environment, I've
had a chance to meet
a few famous chefs,
including yourself now.
And so I wanted to know are
there any chefs that you grew
up watching that inspired
you to continue to cook
and to try to be better?
I know you said, since
high school, yes.
BOBBY FLAY: Well, you have to
understand that Food Network TV
and I were born together.
So there was no Food Network
before I was cooking.
I was already cooking
professionally,
and then Food Network
showed up one day.
And I've been
there for 22 years.
So you know, Julia Child,
the Galloping Gourmet--
do you know who that is?
AUDIENCE: Of course.
BOBBY FLAY: His thing
was really cool.
He would make this gourmet
meal, and it was always
sort of French inspired.
And he always had, like,
this cool jacket on.
And then he'd go up, he'd plate
the meal, pour a glass of wine.
And he'd have a
little table for two.
And he'd go out to the audience
and pick whatever cute girl
he wanted to pick, and
take her by the hand,
and finish having
dinner with her.
I mean, it was really kind
of sweet, actually, you know?
That was the show.
It was Julia Child and
the Galloping Gourmet.
That was really it.
You know, Emeril
really led the charge.
He was on every minute of the
Food Network for so many years.
And I knew Emeril before
he was Emeril, you know?
I mean, we basically grew up
together in this business.
But yeah, I think the
first celebrity chef
that I really knew
was Wolfgang Puck.
I mean, he, in my
opinion, changed
the way we think about
food in America now.
Really, he took food
that was whimsical
and made it incredible.
And made it fun for people
to go to a restaurant
to eat great food.
So you didn't have to go
to some stodgy old place
to eat good food.
He was the first person to take
pizzas and put smoked salmon
and duck sausage on them.
And people were, like,
wow, you can do that?
And he's, like, yeah,
you can do that.
And I always find
it amazing to me,
because it took an Austrian
guy to show America
how to cook good food.
But it's the truth.
I mean, Wolfgang is amazing,
and continues to be.
I mean, some people say
he's got restaurants
in airports and stuff.
Like that.
Yeah, but so what?
I mean, when you go
to his restaurants,
like in LA, he's
there all the time.
I don't know how.
There must be ten of him.
He's always walking
around in his chef white.
He's got his towel
over his shoulder.
He comes up to you.
He sounds like Arnold
Schwarzenegger.
[LAUGHTER]
What's up?
And he cares so much
about what he does.
He's a true leader
of our industry.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You said that
you and Food Network
were born together.
How did Food Network find you?
How did you get started?
BOBBY FLAY: Look, you know,
Food Network was a startup cable
network, and you know,
they had no money.
So the chefs that
were actually being
asked to fill the
time, so to speak,
if you couldn't get
there by subway,
you weren't coming
on the network.
I mean, they weren't flying
people in from California
or anything to do that.
They had no money.
So you know, it was
a 24-hour network.
They had a lot of time to fill.
And so I just started guesting
on different shows as a guest.
And then I said,
you know, I think
I should do a grilling show.
Like, you don't do
anything grilling.
They're, like, what do you mean?
Well, here's a list of
recipes I think we could do.
Like, do you have a name?
Like, yeah, how about
"Grillin' and Chillin'"?
[LAUGHTER]
And they're, like, all right.
I'm not kidding you.
That was the extent
of the meeting.
And then we shot 42 episodes.
That was me and this
guy from Philadelphia.
He was like the country guy.
I was the city guy.
We beat each other up
verbally, kind of fun,
like banter and stuff like that.
You know?
Anyway, like, he would
say to me, I don't--
like, I'd be making
a sauce in a blender.
He's, like, I don't use fancy
equipment like a blender.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, you know.
Anyway, so we shot 42
episodes in six days--
seven a day, live to tape.
And that's why, when I
shoot a cooking show now,
I can shoot-- if I
really wanted to,
I could shoot five in a day.
Because I basically
shoot live to tape.
There was no editing
in those days.
You had to hit the marks
to go to commercial.
So they didn't have the
money to edit, literally.
There was no editing.
I remember when they're, like,
we're going to start editing.
I'm, like, what?
And it was years later.
It was five or six years later.
I did television live
to tape, basically,
for the first six or seven
years of my career there.
So when I do it, when
I do a cooking show now
that has editing, like
I'm doing this new show
with Damaris Phillips,
called "Bobby and Damaris,"
very original name.
And it took us a long time
to figure out that name.
And she was, like, this
is the fastest I've ever
done a cooking show by tenfold.
And I was, like, well, how long
does it take you do a show?
She was, we do, like,
a half a show a day.
And I just don't see
any reason for it.
Because they're trying
to be so perfect.
So when you pick
up the pomegranate,
and they're, like, can
you pick it up again?
No seriously,
that's what happens.
And I go, OK.
What did I do wrong?
Well, I just didn't like
where your hand was.
Who cares?
You're cooking.
And I think part of it is, when
you overshoot a cooking show,
you lose the guts of it.
Because if I make a mistake, it
makes the viewer feel better.
Who cares?
If I burn something
a little bit,
or if I spill
something-- oh, good.
If you spill
something, stop down.
You've got to clear
the whole thing off.
Bring in the more prep, right?
It's insane.
It's totally nuts.
I don't shoot that way.
So I can shoot three
shows, four shows.
We can start at 8
o'clock in the morning.
At 3 o'clock in the
afternoon, I'm having a beer.
And then it feels real.
You want to have your
own cooking show?
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: Yeah, but
what would the theme be?
AUDIENCE: Uh, well--
BOBBY FLAY: Come on.
Pitch me.
This is it right now.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Like, meat
eaters going vegetarian,
like something--
BOBBY FLAY: Well you just--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: --my perspective--
you can have it if you want.
I don't think I have the
caliber to execute right now.
Nick.
BOBBY FLAY: What's
your last name?
AUDIENCE: Gomez.
BOBBY FLAY: Gomez.
So Nick Gomez, the show is--
OK, so vegetarians.
Vegetarians who
were meat eaters?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BOBBY FLAY: OK.
AUDIENCE: I always eat meat, and
it's the basis of everything.
As a kid, I would push
away the vegetables,
and I would grab
for the chicken.
And now the trend is
vegetables and eating healthy.
And the meat is
hard to set aside,
but trying to make vegetables
that I actually want to eat.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BOBBY FLAY: So the show would
basically be you'd have, like,
a big juicy steak over here, and
you'd be, like, all right, just
stay there.
[LAUGHTER]
And then you'd come over
here and saute some zucchini
and convince people that's
what they really want to eat?
AUDIENCE: Like, make
vegetables good enough
to eat for someone
who didn't want
to eat them in the first place?
BOBBY FLAY: That's a good thing.
Absolutely.
Should we give him a show?
AUDIENCE: (SPEAKING
TOGETHER) Yeah!
BOBBY FLAY: All right.
8 o'clock tomorrow.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY FLAY: Cool.
SPEAKER 3: Everybody, help
me thank him for coming.
[APPLAUSE]